YEN-JIE LEE: I decided
to include a lot of demos
during my lectures.
That is because I
believe to learn physics,
you have to know how to convert
everything into mathematics.
You want to work
on the mathematics
and to make predictions,
and finally, you
want to compare the predictions
to experimental data.
Demonstrations are
particularly useful because I
would like to show
that the mathematics we
covered during the
classroom actually
have a lot of consequence.
It's actually really
to do with what
nature does to all the physical
systems we are interested.
So that's actually
why we first--
usually the structure
is like this.
We first introduce
the physical situation
we are interested then
we use the concepts
and the mathematics to
solve the physical system,
and finally, the last part
is to enjoy what we have
learned from this hard work.
To compare our mathematical
solution to reality,
which is actually the demo.
So that is actually why
I introduce so many demos
during the class, and
those, I do think,
using those demos people
will remember more
about the conclusion
we can actually
get from the
mathematics instead of
overwhelmed by a lot of
calculations during the class.
There are so many interesting
demos which we covered.
One of my favorite demos
is the Bell wave machine.
First of all, it's really
a very beautiful demo.
It is so beautiful to
see the sinusoidal wave.
It can be produced from
this simple device.
Secondly, you you can
actually manipulate them,
you can connect
them to each other,
and you can see waves
essentially bouncing
between systems, and then
you can see the reflection
of the traveling wave.
It's so beautiful, and that's
actually my favorite demo
during the class.
I believe most of
the students are also
interested in that
demo very, very much.